تعاني الاف العائلات النازحه شمال غربيه
سوريا من سوق الاوضاع الانسانيه مع انخفاض
درجات الحراره وتساقط الامطار طيله الساعه
الماضيه ما ادى الى تسرب المياه الامطار
الى الخيام في المخيمات العشوائيه
وانتشاري بريك المياه والطين في ازقه
المخيمات وبالتالي صعوبه حركه الاطفال
والنساء وكبار السن بين الخيام يعتمد
النازحون في تامين الدفء لاطفالهم على ما
يشترونهم من اغصان الزيتون وعلى ما
يجمعونه ايضا من المواد البلاستيكيه
والنايلون من مكبات النفايات القريبه من
هنا ليحرقوها في مدافها بدائيه هذه
المدافئ تسببت بامراض كثيره خصوصا للاطفال
للرضع تتحدث عن امراض تنفسيه وامراض جلديه
اضافه غالبيه الاطفال بالانفلونزا الجراء
انخفاض درجات الحراره في ساعات الليل مع
طولي امادي النزوح ووضع في استجابه
المنظمات الانسانيه وكالات الغوث بدا
يريحون يناشدون المجتمع الدولي بايجاد حل
جذري لماساتهم التي تتكرر مع كل شتاء وهي
تامين همم عوده كريمه الى بلداتهم ومدنهم
وارزاقهم بشكل عاجل ادهم ابو الحسام
الجزيره